soir david un point presse hebdomadaire
quasiment sans surprise ce soir
oui c'était fini c'est le veau 1 sans
surprise une visibilité finalement
presque identique qu'avance au point
presse hebdomadaire pour les français
jean castex a d'abord confirmé la
réouverture à des écoles dès ce lundi
pour les crèches maternelles et
primaires un dépistage massif devait
être mis en place avec notamment les
déploiements à des autos ce test et des
tests salivaires dans les établissements
scolaires un choix assumé à par
l'exécutif est une fierté d'avoir
répondu aux objectifs affichés
1 concernant l'éducation nationale
écouter le premier ministre nous en
réalisions 258 par semaine fin mars nous
en proposerons 400000 par semaine à la
reprise avec la perspective d'atteindre
600 mille tests d'ici la mi mai nous
concentrerons ce dispositif de dépistage
dans les départements où l'incidence est
la plus élevée
en complément des tests salivaires la
grande nouveauté de la reprise sera le
déploiement des autotests il s'agit d'un
prélèvement nasal
mais beaucoup plus simple et léger que
pour les tests pcr et dont le résultat
est connu en 15 minutes
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a par la suite
détaillé le protocole sanitaire
territorialisée qui sera mise en place
dès lundi très david les écoles
largement abordés durant ce point presse
mais les français
espérait également avoir plus de
précisions pour sur le retour à une vie
normale
oui hélas aussi stéphanie encore
beaucoup de flou ans même si vous l'avez
dit la situation à sanitaire s'améliore
le premier ministre s'est montré très
prudent et n'a rien dévoilé ou presque
adieu calendrier a dû déconfinement
néanmoins l'exécutif promet de lever les
restrictions aux déplacements le 3 mai
prochain ce sera la fin à des
attestations et à de l'interdiction des
déplacements
pour ce qui est du couvre-feu en
revanche le gouvernement a confirmé que
celui-ci restera quoi qu'il arrive en
vigueur jusqu'à la mi-mai pour la
réouverture des terrasses des bars et
restaurants de celle des lieux culturels
l'échéance à la limette est confirmée
écouter à partir du 3 mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement en journée est envisagée
sous réserve de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire
un nouveau train de réouverture autour
de la mine est qu'ils pourraient
commencer par les commerces certaines
activités culturelles et sportives et
les terrasses
cette liste n'est pas définitivement
fixée elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
voilà aussi là aussi à beaucoup de
prudence à cause notamment des variants
sud africains brésiliens ou indiens un
durcissement des conditions d'entrée sur
le territoire pour tous les voyageurs
issus de ce pays a été annoncé également
par le premier ministre et dernier point
abordé ce soir la campagne de
vaccination avec encore une fois une
défense sans relâche d'astrazeneca
sans relâche c'est le mot exact
stéphanie tous les membres du
gouvernement présents ce soir en
prononcer le mot à sera à zenica jean
castex a d'abord à rappeler que
l'exécutif rattraper son retard dans le
calendrier vaccinal initial là aussi
avec une certaine forme
d'autosatisfaction et cette phrase nous
affichons un rythme de vaccination par
avril et plus rapide d'europe l'objectif
de vacciner 20 millions de français à la
mi mai et 30 millions à la mi juin est
toujours d'actualité
et pour cela et bien il faut convaincre
les français que astrazeneca est sans
danger puisque les doses peine à trouver
des receveurs volontaire le chef du
gouvernement a donc tenté de redonner du
crédit aux vaccins britannique au
suédois pointé du doigt pour ses effets
indésirables et notamment à quelques cas
de thrombose olivier vers ans a pour
cela a tenté de nuancer en utilisant des
comparatifs de la vie quotidienne
écoutez le ministre de la santé dans de
très rares cas il peut provoquer des
thromboses c'est à dire la formation de
petits cailloux qui peuvent aller
bouchée des haines qui peuvent aller
boucher la circulation d'henneuse et
provoquer pour le coup des effets
indésirables plus graves mais ils sont
très rares c'est cinq cas environ pour
un million de personnes vaccinées
je vous donnais une comparaison si vous
prenez l'avion pour traverser
l'atlantique
vous avez un risque également de faire
des thromboses parce que vous allez être
moins mobiles et ce risque
si vous traversez l'atlantique en avion
il est 50 fois plus élevé que si vous
faites d'actionner par astra zeneca ça
permet quand même je crois de
relativiser les choses
minimiser les risques encourus pour
convaincre un maximum de français de se
faire vacciner avec astrazeneca c'était
l'objectif annoncé est affichée de
l'exécutif
ce soir hormis ça vous l'aurez compris
il faudra patienter jusqu'à la prise de
parole des manuels macron pour avoir un
calendrier est plus nette plus clair
dieu déconfinement lorsque viendra le
temps des bonnes nouvelles
merci à david california en est loin et
à ce propos d'ailleurs ne prend pas de
temps que ça l'avion donc pour reprendre
la métaphore du ministre de la santé pas
beaucoup de risques en ce moment de ce
point de vue
ah merci à vous